pensez un peu plus aujourd'hui sur la
logistique de vaccination au canada
alors qu'au royaume uni
on commencera à vacciner lundi l' dans
deux jours alors le plan de distribution
au canada bon il va se met en branle
puis ça devrait se dérouler assez
rapidement dès qu'on aura la livraison
de ce fameux vaccin
mais selon un sondage de radio canada 64
pour cent des canadiens vont aller se
faire vacciner lorsque le vaccin sera
disponible y en a quand même chanté 11%
qui craignent des effets secondaires
malgré les risques très faible sur les
chiffres de santé canada compilée par
mon collègue thomas gerber mais la
vaccination reste quand même un terreau
fertile pour les forces nouvelles et la
désinformation fait le point avec alexis
blanc sert journalistes et animateurs
des décrypteurs de relever que le sujet
passionne
bonsoir alexis bonjour la mairie alors
refusé que le phénomène des anti vaccins
la désinformation la au sujet de la
vaccination
c'était déjà présents bien avant la
pandémie oui je te rival on l'avait vu
avec la controverse entourant le tisme
que certains liés évidemment de façon
erronée à la vaccination eu l'épisode du
h1n1 on avait vu se déployer le discours
anti vaccins à ce moment là ou si bon
cette fois-ci vous évoquez les chefs
rebelles mari de ceux de ce chantage du
tiers des gens grosso modo qui se disent
prêts à se faire vacciner 70 % - environ
qui disent avoir des craintes par
rapport aux effets secondaires et quand
même un quart 25% qui se dit
généralement contre les vaccins et c'est
important d'établir d'entrée de jeu
l'existence de spectres cécile c'est
peut-être normal d'être dans ce qu'on
appelle l'hésitation vaccinale
d'introduire un doute raisonnable envers
les vaccins mais c'est une autre chose
et ça c'est à l'autre bout du spectre
que d'entretenir une passe et
conspirationnistes basé sur la la
vaccination entourant la vaccination je
veux simplement rétablir les choses
parce qu'on au dos du vaccin qu'on était
un conspirationniste pas quand on
regarde les chiffres
grosso modo ce qu'on constate aussi s'il
n'ya pas nécessairement une érosion
marque et de la cohésion envers la
vaccination mais ce qu'on observe le
décrypteur et ce qu'observe d'autres
personnes c'est qu'il ya très clairement
une guerre asymétrique une guerre si on
veut inégale sur les réseaux sociaux
entre le discours pro vaccin et le
discours anti vaccins
j'attire votre attention sur une étude
qui était publié en mai dernier par le
magazine scientifique nature où on avait
on serait penché sur un épisode
important
une éclosion important de rougeole en
2019 on avait passé au peigne fin des
milliers de publications sur facebook
je résume ça pour se rendre compte à
quel point le disco anti vaccins avaient
été nettement plus efficace nettement
mieux
réseauter avec un taux de pénétration
beaucoup plus marquée dans les espaces
virtuels ces réseaux sociaux dits
neutres qui n'était pas nécessairement
acquis à la cause des anti vaccins mais
il y était lui présent ce discours avait
eu un net avantage face au discours au
vaccin
alors pour bien illustrer ou résumer
cette guerre asymétrique je vous propose
d'écouter notre invité de cette semaine
à l'émission les décrypteurs
jean-françois klich qui est journaliste
scientifique au quotidien le soleil
c'est un peu comme si les les grandes
organisations sanitaires étaient comme
une grande armée napoléonienne qui est
fait qui est très bonne pour gagner des
batailles sur un grand champ de bataille
ouvert où les deux armées peuvent se
voir
sauf que les groupes anti vaccins c'est
plus une bière ignore qui font un petit
coup parti coup vient presser ils vont
du sport plus pauvres à rien je pense
que la plupart des groupes anti vaccins
évite les débats publics avec des vrais
experts d'habitude quand ils le font ça
se passe vraiment pouviez pour ceux qui
font plus la guérilla des petits coups
sur facebook is yellow avant de se
retirer
évidemment est ce que ces discours entre
l'accès à profiter de la pandémie
ben ça c'est la grande question je crois
qu'il est un peu tôt pour pouvoir en
tirer des conclusions mais josé certaine
et la réflexion est tout naturel quand
on entend les frais de monsieur klich
tout à l'heure il va alors faire quelque
chose des gestes un peu plus avant une
présence un peu plus grande dans les
réseaux sociaux déjà facebook cette
semaine pas plus tard que jeudi a décidé
ou annoncé plus tôt la suppression cours
des prochaines semaines des prochains
mois tout au long de cette campagne de
vaccination inédite de toutes les
publications qui auront été désavoué par
les autorités médicales et sanitaires
voilà est-ce que c'est trop peu trop
tard à vous d'en juger
la france 54 % des gens 54 % seulement
se disent prêts à se faire vacciner
c'est un pays aussi énormément de
scepticisme et
aussi de discours marqué anti vaccins eh
bien il ya des gens sur les réseaux
sociaux la france où se sont dit bah ça
il faut qu'on s'organise il faut qu'on
organise aussi une réplique en plus ou
moins concertées basée sur des faits
scientifiques avérées et c'est ça ce
qu'on observe sur le terrain parce qu'il
faut bien avoir conscience de la
rhétorique des conspirationnistes qui
fait mouche à bien des égards
par exemple lorsqu'on utilise et c'est
ce que l'on noté olivier klein des
toxicologues social en belgique qui j'ai
parlé on utilise un discours où on parle
à hauteur de personnes vont vous dis
voilà les faits faites votre public et
en contrepartie de l'état qui avec un
discours moins des actes d un cas plus
de s'incarner plutôt attire moins
peut-être certaines personnes qui sont
dans le doute parce qu'il faut bien se
dire une chose nous décrypte heure où
les gens qui veulent contrer le message
anti vaccins il faut pas se mettre dans
la tête qu'on va convertir les gens qui
sont profondément anti vaccins il faut
plutôt se concentrer sur les personnes
qu'ils aiment et qu'ils sont habités par
ce doute qui peut être sain naturel
quand on voit la vitesse avec laquelle
en ce moment levac sessions sont
développés alors c'est accepter hauteur
là qu'il faut c'est à ce niveau là je
pense qu'il faut agir
si on veut tranquillement a
progressivement collectivement vaincre
le ce discours pour le bien évidemment
de la santé publique autonome et de
l'important don de vous écouter demain
au décryptage
mais aussi de retourner aux thèmes
notamment géré mais qui qui mentionne
les chefs de santé canada qui sont des
faits là sur des millions de doses que
250 f est peut-être plus grave mais
seulement quatre décès mais qui ont sont
promis aux vaccins qui sont liées à une
condition préexistante exactement ceci
dire à ces personnes je comprends qu'un
risque mais est-ce que ce risque est
plus grand que la des risques encourus
par la maladresse ce niveau là qu'il
faut dialoguer dialogue et l'empathie
c'est essentiel merci alex et avoir leur
coeur et merci